I think all Manchester United fans will  be pleased to see the back of them I  think they've  some of what question are Christian  Ronaldo said this week was I thought  quite interesting when he basically said  look going back there after 15 years the  ground has deteriorated the training  ground has deteriorated I think they  haven't spent the money on the club and  they've done it because they've been  taking  a large amount of money out now having  said that football fans would always  want uh  money to stay in the club and not and  not be paid out to shareholders so but I  do think I think Manchester United fans  generally will be celebrating today